i know
you filmed the movie in the bloom
family's real house so i was wondering
if there's anything about your portrayal
of sam and cam
that you might not have been able to tap
into had it not been for that shooting
location
well for me i felt pretty close to sam
by the time we got to the location
i'd had a series of great meetings
and phone calls in the lead up um and
um she really was just so generous
and accessible every every um
step of the way and um the house was
yeah definitely unusual i've never had
that experience before where you're
you're literally in their space um
but it it is it's just another one of
those tools that helps you get closer
i felt like i knew everything um i also
was able to read her diaries which she
so generously shared
um but yeah living in the house or
playing in the house that they lived in
um
gave us further information i mean you
see that backdrop
um right there what she had to look at
every day
which was the beauty and reason for
living kind of thing
one day and then the next day it became
a punish
like the haunting aspect of all of the
things that she could no longer enjoy
so yeah getting grasping hold of that
was
useful information i'm also still very
blown away by
the choice to shoot the film with real
magpies so
is there anything that happened during
the shoot that didn't go to plan and you
had to adjust to what the birds were
doing and
maybe that adjustment was for the better
yeah they
they they never do what they're being
asked to do
just to qualify they are i mean look we
had an
amazing bird trainer called paul who was
remarkable but they
are you know you have wiggly worms
in order to encourage them and they have
to be live worms in order to move them
around
into certain places but once they're fed
like most actors
they don't want to work who knows so uh
so we would uh was it jerry
would go leave and then we would have
wendell one take when
uh wendell that she would come in and
then
she would get fed and so it was a sort
of you sort of
you you dealt with what you was in front
of you very much like the children
that were there as well who'd never been
on a film set before so
it was quite a thrilling experience all
round
they are all so good in the movie birds
and children included
naomi this feels like there's no simple
and quick answer to this but one of my
favorite parts of the movie
is that it manages to give you hope but
without ever
sugarcoating or lessening the severity
of sam's experience so
what did you talk through with glendon
or maybe even
sam herself in order to find that right
balance there
yeah i mean i'm allergic to
sentimentality i i don't i don't like it
at all um and i i have a radar
so it was i was but there's a sweet spot
right there's a
there's a little moment in there where
you want to tell
how um you know moving the story is and
how
painful that was and then and then slip
into the world of hope and
recovery and restoring um one's
beliefs and um so but it just
we were all really mindful of staying
away from
pressing buttons and manipulating
audiences
um and that was important to sam most of
all
and you know um it begins with her and
she
opened up her herself in ways that
um we were able to access all kinds of
truths that
hopefully are there on the screen you
feel it big time i also really wanted to
ask you about working with emma cooper
on this because i was wondering how your
relationship and collaboration
grew from emma being a unit publicist on
so many of your movies to
you producing a full feature alongside
her oh that's such an interesting
question yeah emma cooper is an old old
friend of mine
um decades long and yes from working as
um a publicist but she also had a
business prior to
that that where she was organizing all
kinds of events so
you know she knows how to run a tight
chip and produce
anything she brought the book to me
and um through bradley trevor grief
and we said right there after i read it
that time that first time
leafing through the pages with my
children and being completely swept up
in this story
she said do you see it as a film do you
want
does it pull you into that world and i
said absolutely
the magic of this bird has such great
cinematic values and
um this is a story of hope and
resilience and
i see it as a film let's do it andrew i
got a two-parter for you right now
because i believe this is your first
feature since
even starting walking dead so i was
wondering
one why choose to focus on walking dead
and not load up your schedule with
movies in between
seasons and also after having had an
experience focusing on
that show for so long even though the
material here is completely different
is there anything about that experience
that you find coming in handy in the
project you take on now
great questions i mean the first
question is
uh i i have a young family and
uh you know the industry is littered
with
you know people that don't make it as a
family and and i spent eight months
away from them for a loss of their
childhood
uh and i it was becoming
more unbearable so i would you know so
basically when i was home
uh i was playing catch up as a parent as
a husband and as a father
and also you know unfortunately what hap
what you have to do is you have to
change people's uh perceptions of what
you're
able to do as an actor and so a lot of
the scripts i was receiving
were great scripts but they were action
and they were horror
and um and i just thought you know what
i
i was waiting for the right story to
chime
and then this one came along and i
instantly loved it knew i wanted to be a
part of this beautiful story of
you know the bloom family and then we
know he was involved in yada yada it
just was a no-brainer
uh what i i've learned working in
america
uh i will i i think i improved as an
actor working in america
working at the scale that our show was
on and working with really
really fine uh filmic actors in america
you know it's great being trained in the
uk
um but there's something about working
with
really the best on screen
that kind of ups your game and and the
alchemy of just sort of
the endeavor of trying to get it better
there isn't a set
way of doing it and that was something
that certainly working with this
there's never a set way of working with
children and animals
um and so yeah i think you learn as you
go
and you grow as hopefully as an actor as
you get more experience
so i was recently talking to rachel
house and one of the things that i was
so struck by during that conversation
was her emphasis
on culture on sets i suppose one of the
um
main qualities um we have
uh something called manaki tanga in our
is the practice and principles of
uplifting
um and each other with respect
and um care and generosity
given the fact that that's not something
we see in hollywood that often is there
anything about the culture on this set
that really struck you that you wish you
saw more out there i think
the tone was set by sam and cam and the
need to honor their stories
and um and that just sort of trickled
all the way down
we had beautiful families involved
the the kids on screen and their
families
in the background were very much
involved my kids were there andrew's
kids were there
um we had jackie we had rachel we had
friends as producers we had
um friends as actors it was
it was just a warmth and there was a
respect for the truth
of honoring this story this difficult
story
and rachel when she came in
she blew us all away with her energy and
her
um she was just a breath of fresh air
because you know
we've we've been doing all these quite
tricky scenes that we're dealing with
the grief of
sam's um you know accident and
um and then she's just like this beam of
light
and i i mean one of my favorite scenes
in the whole movie is with rachel
um we improvised this moment in the sea
where we
just belting out radiohead and um we
touch each other's faces and
it was just so like emblematic of how we
were feeling
about each other and as you say the
culture of the film it felt really
um a warm and safe place comes through
big time i am obsessed with your movie
huge congratulations to both of you it's
exactly what i needed right now
well good thank you